[Musica]
nel 1990 io ho 14 anni e un giorno mi
trovo di fronte a uno spacciatore ma non
è come pensate uscito da scuola in tipo
in un vicolo buio non ho e sono in una
una grande sala e di fronte ad almeno
altre 50 persone è un corso di sviluppo
personale e mio papà il guru ed è lui
che mi ha messo in questa situazione si
aspetta che io dica qualcosa che scuota
questo ragazzo che gli faccia cambiare
rotta
sì io sono il figlio del guru però sono
anche timido e insicuro di fronte a 50
persone a uno spacciatore è a mio padre
faccio un passo indietro non reggo
appena posso mi rifugio dietro una
colonna e per fortuna in quella stanza
ce n'erano veramente tante sta di fatto
che vi ho raccontato l'episodio
emblematico ma la mia vita prima e dopo
è stata molto simile
finché nel 2003
mio padre mi chiama e mi dice che è
ammalato e in quelle settimane io ho la
fortuna perché di fortuna si tratta di
accompagnarlo nel suo percorso terminale
posso vedere la sua fragilità
posso vedere la sua vulnerabilità posso
vedere i suoi errori
tutte cose che erano davanti ai miei
occhi ma semplicemente non avevo mai
visto da quel giorno per me il limite
non è più solo sinonimo di frustrazione
diventa sinonimo di umanità incontrando
la sua umanità
imparo a incontrare anche la mia imparo
ad accettarmi inizio ad accettarmi anche
se sono timido anche se sono insicuro
anche se non mi piaccio meglio tutte
queste cose
già le sapevo allora ma in realtà non
l'avevo ancora comprese
oggi mi occupo di sviluppo del
potenziale e incontro tante persone che
come me allora hanno lo stesso bug sono
convinte che migliorarsi significhi
necessariamente raggiungere obiettivi
incredibili come se tutti quanti
dovessimo diventare campioni alle
olimpiadi
oppure pensano di dover adempiere come
delle aspettative altrui e e di fronte a
tutto questo come di fronte a una
montagna noi è semplicemente abbiamo
paura e quindi rinunciamo o recitiamo
portiamo nel mondo solo una parte quella
quella che più ci rassicura quella che
ci ha portato fin qua allora chi ha
sempre lottato che ha sempre aggredito
la vita davanti ad aggredire sempre
comunque anche quando magari gli si
tende una mano chi è arrivato fin lì
grazie al metodo alla precisione alla
cura di ogni dettaglio continua a fare
solo questo e magari di nasce un figlio
e mette in excel tutti gli adattamenti
chi è arrivato dove è arrivato grazie
alla disponibilità grazie alla
condiscendenza va avanti a dire sempre
sì sì sì anche quando non ce la fa più
anche quando dovrebbe dire un no ci
difendiamo e e diciamo io sono fatto
così ma in realtà forse dovremmo
imparare a dire io sono anche fatto così
e poi incontro persone che sono molto
bravi a vedere i limiti negli altri
vedono i limiti del loro capo che non
decide mai
ok troppo aggressivo i limiti dei
collaboratori che semplicemente non sono
autonomi o non hanno abbastanza
proattività i limiti dei colleghi che
sono troppo competitivi e che cercano di
farsi gli sgambetti i limiti dei
conoscenti i limiti
degli amici i limiti dei familiari e
l'incontro altre che sono molte di meno
che sanno riportare il limite su di se
ne ricordo una in particolare un
amministratore delegato nel 2017 una
persona rispettata di successo che di
fronte a tutte le sue prime linee apre
una riunione dicendo il limite più
grande al raggiungimento dei nostri
obiettivi oggi sono io perché no non ho
mai imparato a fidarmi perché non delego
perché di controllo eccessivamente e su
questo vi chiedo una mano
bene quelle parole furono uno
spartiacque per quel gruppo di lavoro
per quella persona ma non tanto perché
tutti quanti le condividevano perché
ovviamente tutti le condividevano e
quando si lamentavano di quella
amministratore delegato dicevano
esattamente questo quelle parole furono
uno spartiacque perché quella persona fu
capace di mettere sul tavolo una propria
verità e questo lo sappiamo dal peso che
quelle parole avevano nella sua bocca
dall'imbarazzo e dalla vergogna che ha
dovuto superare per poter dire una prima
volta in pubblico ad alta voce davanti a
tutti quello che tutti già sapevano e
tutti già pensavano allora magari puoi
pensare che esporre un tuo limite porti
gli altri a potersene approfittare
questo certo è possibile ma dall'altra
parte
prova a vedere il tuo limite come un
punto di partenza
allora la domanda è indipendentemente da
dove tu voglia andare e voglia di fare
il primo passo o di rimanere immobile
beh io poi questa esplorazione lo
continuata
ci ho preso gusto e la provocazione è
stata il bicchiere bicchiere d'acqua
quello che lo guardiamo e ci chiediamo è
mezzo pieno e mezzo vuoto
che poi la differenza vera e farsi
un'altra domanda e chiedersi ma questo
bicchiere l'acqua che c'è qua dentro io
che cosa ci voglio fare cosa che ci vuoi
fare
a voi bere più e fare uno scherzo lo
vuoi farti una doccia
vuoi bagnare una pianta com'è che la
vuoi usare ho scoperto che esistono dei
cocci riparati con coloro che diventano
delle opere stupende ho scoperto che
esistono marciapiedi pieni di buche
lastricate da dei mosaici colorati e
quindi ho iniziato a chiedermi come
anche i miei difetti potessero diventare
delle risorse e degli strumenti il
difetto ha in sé una coazione a ripetere
ci costringe a fare sempre la stessa
cosa a cadere sempre nello stesso errore
ma se io imparo a gestire quella
questione a ripetere se imparo a
decidere io quando comportarmi in quel
modo forse posso tenerlo come uno
strumento posso preservarne l'energia
io ad esempio grazie alla timidezza
forse qualcosa hanno sviluppato
timidezza mi ha sempre portato a fare un
passo indietro a mettere gli altri sul
palcoscenico e quindi ho sviluppato
curiosità perché quello era il modo
migliore inizialmente per stare dietro
la colonna ma dall'altra parte ho
imparato a fare domande e oggi posso
dire che sono in grado di fare delle
domande e sappiamo che una buona domanda
è già meta risposta questo signore e
django rheinhard e credo sia l'emblema
di quello che sto raccontando nel 1928
django ha 18 anni ed è già un affermato
un musicista sono al banjo blair
sta di fatto che a 18 anni si ritrova
purtroppo in un incendio
la sua roulotte va a fuoco e lui rischia
la vita e ne esce veramente menomato ha
problemi alla gamba pro è un musicista
ma soprattutto ha grossi problemi alla
mano sinistra
i medici sono in dubbio addirittura se
dove gli ad amputare riescono a salvarla
ma la mano rimane segnata due ditte sono
addirittura fuse django reihnardt non
può più suonare il banjo è uno strumento
troppo duro e uno strumento troppo
ruvido però prende mano la chitarra
prendi mano la chitarra e succede
qualcosa di incredibile perché la sua
menomazione
lo costringe a inventare qualcosa di
nuovo lo costringe a suonare in un modo
in cui nessuno prima di lui aveva mai
suonato gianco rail ad lascerà un segno
nella musica non solo del dei suoi anni
ma anche nella musica a venire ed è
ricordato come uno dei più grandi
chitarristi della storia allora prova a
fartela questa domanda se impari ad
andare oltre il giudizio che hai per i
tuoi difetti se inizi a guardare i tuoi
difetti accettandoli e imparando a
gestirli come uno strumento a me viene
semplicemente me gyver macgyver prendeva
una forcina per capelli ne va una una
latta spray in mezza consumata due
batterie e costruiva è qualcosa di
incredibile beh allora i difetti
magari sono la stessa cosa sono un
materiale di scarto con il quale
possiamo creare qualcosa di interessante
e poi se vogliamo giocare quei limiti
con i difetti
io vorrei proporvi un passo in più un
passo ulteriore di prendere
l'atteggiamento dell'esploratore
dell'avventuriero perché in fin dei
conti lo sviluppo del potenziale è
proprio questo è proprio avere la voglia
di esplorare un qualche cosa in più
e allora l'avventuriero me lo immagino
di fronte a un incredibile foresta fitta
in cui nessuno è mai entrato
e sicuramente spaventato all'idea di
entrarci però dall'altra parte è anche
curioso e anche desideroso di essere il
primo che lascia il segno lì dentro
in fin dei conti sviluppare il proprio
potenziale vuol dire proprio questo vuol
dire essere in grado di avere questo
tipo di attitudine vuol dire essere in
grado anche in un certo senso di darsi
dei permessi di darsi delle
autorizzazioni tutti quanti abbiamo
paura di sbagliare è evidente il tema è
quanto coraggio riusciamo a mettere
nell'esplorazione che facciamo
io ad esempio ho iniziato a esplorare la
possibilità di litigare non ho mai avuto
questa attitudine sono sempre stato
molto orientato alla mediazione nella
mia vita
eppure a un certo punto
hanno goduto l'esperienza liberatoria e
devo dirlo divertente di un bel litigio
che è assolutamente una cosa fantastica
io ve lo consiglio se voi non siete
capaci di litigare dovete imparare
poi è chiaro che questa cosa di imparare
a gestirla e quindi inizialmente fi
errori nel mio caso il litigio rotto dei
piatti va bene e poi impari a gestirla
chiaramente però il valore è stato
quello di attraversare questa cosa del
valore è stato quello di non fermarsi di
fronte alla paura di poter fare un
errore allora quanti sono quelle quei
difetti sui quali magari è un po di
paura e che tendi a non hanno lasciarti
la possibilità di esplorare perché in
fin dei conti se per la paura di essere
pigri ad esempio noi non ci autorizziamo
alla possibilità di un po di ozio un po
di rilassatezza un po di anche la
creatività che nasce nel nell'essere in
un momento di di pause di noia forse ci
stiamo perdendo qualcosa se per la paura
di essere visti come arroganti
noi non ci concediamo un momento di
palcoscenico un momento in cui ci
mettiamo davanti a tutti e faccia
sentire la nostra voce il palcoscenico è
il modo attraverso il quale la tua voce
può arrivare a più persone se se se per
la paura di essere arroganti non ti
metti nel palcoscenico
forse davvero ti stai perdendo qualcosa
e se per la paura di essere fragili se
per la paura
di essere vulnerabili non c'è
utilizziamo un momento in cui ci apriamo
di fronte agli altri in cui raccontiamo
che ci tenevamo a quella cosa che ci
tenevamo davvero se non ci lasciamo
toccare per la paura di essere fragili
forse ci siamo davvero perdendo qualcosa
se per la paura dell'aggressività se per
la paura di essere di essere troppo
forti ci perdiamo l'opportunità di far
sentire la nostra voce di di essere
fermi di essere determinati di arrivare
diretti e spontanea e le cose forse ci
stiamo perdendo qualcosa se per la paura
della pazzia
se per la paura dell'essere giudicati
fuori di testa non ci consentì amo un
momento di leggerezza un momento di
gioco un momento di divertimento forse
davvero ci stiamo perdendo qualcosa ho
sentito alcune volte fare questa domanda
se incontrassi il te stesso da giovane
che cosa gli diresti
io ho pensato che cosa direi se
incontrassi quel quattordicenne che si
nascondeva dietro le colonne e credo che
non gli direi nulla perché tutta la
strada che ha fatto è tutta la strada
che farà anche gli errori in realtà sono
i passi che servono sono i passi
perfetti e quando noi veramente
riusciamo a superare un limite che ci
riusciamo oppure no ce ne accorgiamo
solo a posteriori
quindi credo che il valore vero di tutto
questo percorso sia avere la fiducia e
continuare a camminare grazie